[Music]
I want people to hear my
[Applause]
voice and just forget their troubles for
minutes do you know what girl power
means to meet Sarah Bourn Lauren Hill
you need to know this I ain't no Spice
Girl from primary
school to sell out concerts it's going
to happen one of these days boys like
yours got to it's one of the best of
ever own that's my daughter that's my
Amy I met someone tonight stay lucky Amy
got an i for have B
boys the album's number one around the
world the highest shotting album from a
British female artist in the
US
[Applause]
ever I don't think I was put on this
Earth just to sing me I want to be a
wife I want to be a
mom probably run off for someone famous
anyway you're my heartbeat you're my
soul I love you
tears I don't bang out tenants by lunch
I need to live my songs so that's what
I'm going to go and do
ready we
[Music]
only I don't write songs to be
famous I write songs
cuz I've got to make something good out
something
[Applause]
bad
[Music]